let's start with that should we off-gen
warning these companies that they're
just not doing enough yes not a good
report for the energy companies from off
Gem and I mean you want the regulator to
be highlighting where things are not
going right but I'm aware I mean in my
constituency I have a significant
British gas call center that often deals
with the most vulnerable customers and I
know there are things that the energy
companies do but that list of of
complaints there is not a good story I
think energy companies have got to
realize people want them to be proactive
at this really difficult time doing
everything they can but again it's a
sign for me that the government's
management of the energy Market has not
been a good story for the last 12 years
yeah but they're doing everything the
government's doing everything they can
to try to help people at this incredibly
difficult stage at one stage offering
two cap bills for about for two years
although that's changed now well that
has changed now I think the government's
charge sheet on energy is that over the
last 12 years they've made some really
poor decisions things like Bunning
onshore wind which is the cheapest form
of electricity production having no real
ambition on Energy Efficiency or
canceling the insulation program they
themselves put forward in the 2010
general election your bills are higher
than they otherwise need to be in whilst
they'll always be emergencies crises and
this one is an energy crisis that's
clearly begun through the the situation
in Ukraine and Russia's Invasion our
resilience as a country that is the
responsibility of the government and I
think we've gone into these crises
unprepared or not as well prepared as we
could have been had they pursued better
choices over the last 12 years your boss
is talking to the CBI today amongst
other things a couple of things to talk
about first of all off the back of this
he says that we should be greener and
Kinder how are we going to do that well
Net Zero is something this country has
to do when the rest of the world has to
follow us in that mission as well but
it's also a source of potentially a
great many skilled green jobs and if you
look at what labor has put forward what
we call our green Prosperity plan it's a
plan for how we can work in in
partnership with business to deliver
those jobs so whether that's in you know
battery factories that we need for the
automotive industry whether that's in
new exciting Industries like green
hydrogen what we haven't got at the
minute is a long-term strategy that
gives businesses the confidence to
invest or the kind of partnership with
the state the public money that needs to
go in that will make these very exciting
new technologies investable so that is
that's part a key part of our growth
plan and that is what Kia is going to
put forward at the CBI today as well as
some other issues responding to the
needs of business indeed so including
talking about what's going on with uh
brexit a labor wants a points-based
system
um how's that going to work well this is
the immigration system and skills and
labor shortages are I think the number
one issue that businesses raised with me
all the time and I understand that the
system is not working for them at the
moment particularly in terms of how long
it takes to get visas and how the
shortage occupation list Works which
allows real skill gaps in the economy to
be addressed more quickly now we want to
be pragmatic on that and address those
needs but what Kira is going to say to
businesses today is if businesses do
want to bring additional people to the
country well that's got to be matched by
a clear plan for greater investment in
skills in the UK for better pay in
conditions and for investment in new
technology so that means immigration is
going to continue to play a significant
role in our economy we should be proud
of people who come to this country to do
it but it's not the sole means by which
we meet those skills and labor shortages
I think that's a good system that meets
the needs of business but also is a much
more sound one for the country as a
whole so is he still defending um free
movement of people or not no because
free movement of people make sense if
you're a member of the European Union
but now that issue is settled we've
moved on from that the system well I
think there are real deficiencies in the
trading Corporation group that we have
with the European Union we've set out
some specific things we would like to
see things like a Veterinary agreement
with the EU the mutual recognition of
professional qualifications we want to
rejoin the Horizon Science Program which
is very important but on this on the
issue immigration I don't think freedom
of movement makes any sense if you're
outside billion vacancies
um you know and we can't fill them the
only way to do that is to allow people
to come in and do those jobs yes but and
we're going to still have that as part
of what gear is putting forward today
but I mean let's be clear immigration to
the UK stands at over 200 000 people a
year we should be proud of people
wanting to come to this country and do
that but it cannot be the sole means by
which we meet those vacancies we want to
see for instance more people who are
currently not able to work us they're
not very well addressed by for instance
our plan to abolish the non-dome rule
and expand the NHS Workforce which is
what the NHS needs but it's also a way
of getting people the health care they
need to get them back into the economy
we want to make sure in sectors where
there are deficiencies in terms of
paying conditions the migration advisory
committee advises on that so we know
exactly what those sectors needs so
immigration is going to continue to play
a role but I think it needs more kind of
role what sort of percentage role given
let's say there's let's say a million
million a half depends which figures you
look at how quickly can labor fill that
whole if they come into power and how
much of that would be people with
migration how many would be um people
from the UK look if you believe as we do
that immigration must be fundamentally
about the needs of the economy with this
balance between the investment going in
in skills development in the UK
alongside people coming in I don't think
it's useful to set an arbitrary number
if you remember when the government had
the conservative government had that net
migration Target of tens of thousands I
mean they got nowhere near that there
were hundreds of thousands of people off
that every year so I don't think that is
helpful in itself but I think if you
have the kind of policies we're putting
forward today that here is articulating
to the CBI with with this better balance
in place there would be less of a
dependence solely on immigration as the
means to fill those needs yeah but how
quickly will you be able to fill those
uh job vacancies there at the moment
even if we're talking about upskilling
workers who who do or don't want to go
back to work many over 55 just don't
after the pandemic for all sorts of
reasons it's going to take time so how
are you going to fill that Gap it does
take time but first of all responding
didn't just work for us yes that will
require those people to be trained and
able to do that I think there are
changes to how job center plus Works in
terms of how the government's employment
programs work as well where there are
specific sectors let's say technical
jobs in manufacturing look I think those
are the kind of things you could look to
in terms of allowing a great new people
to come to the country to fulfill them
but that's exactly the sort of example
where you would need alongside that as
we're putting forward today a clear plan
for better skills training in the UK to
fulfill those needs because over time it
does take time but that's why I think
the balance here that he's putting
forward is the right balance it's
pragmatic to the needs of business but
it also is saying over the long term
we're not going to solely look to
immigration as the only means of
fulfilling those vacancies how do you
think well it's got on last night I
think well first of all I'm most excited
about England if you'll forgive me for
saying that but I think it's a really
really good point for Wales and it's
quite exciting for all the home nations
are you watching we had a business
reception who do a lot of business
receptions in the shadow business
secretary in the leaders offices in
pardon but we had the game on as well
and Welsh colleagues made absolutely
clear their support and enthusiasm for
the result okay
um should
we be playing in Casa
I think we should we're right to ghoul I
think you know World Cups are so
important in terms of
football fans and actually the overall
impact of everyone in the country how
they feel about these big sporting
tournaments I I'm not happy with the
World Cup being in Qatar I think the
argument for extending the the
destinations who've been able to host
the World Cup has always been an
argument that's been put forward about
taking the values of football the
universality of that kind of a
conversation with somebody you can still
have a game of football with them and
spreading that out and it feels to me so
far it's guitar changing football rather
than football changing guitar so I think
it's been a poor choice and FIFA are
accountable for that but I wouldn't say
we should boycott it and not have the
team play there should Mount Drakes
would be there who's the leader of
course of the Welsh labor party well I
mean Mark Griffith is the leader of the
league of Wales and he can make his own
decisions on that I I wouldn't
personally what do you think to guitar I
wouldn't personally go no but should he
have gone well I think from a personal
perspective that's all I can give and I
think it's perhaps different if you are
you know the first minister of of Wales
I I feel that first of all in a cost of
living crisis this you know a
lot of politicians going to a World Cup
might not be actually the best message
to send out but I think more than that
what's different about Qatar we've had
your major sporting events in in quite
troubling countries in the past but I
think the
the fact that the construction of the
stadiums has directly led to some
incredibly negative uh consequences for
migrant workers
you know that is that is for me I think
different to what we've seen in the past
but I'm not going to speak for anybody
else my personal view is that no no but
I mean your leader has said that he's
not going to go and yet the leader of
the party in Wales has gone and and I
just wondered how you square that Circle
well look that's Evolution and people
you know kid doesn't issue the orders to
all parts of the UK it's quite right the
people we respect that difference and
that ability to people to make their own
choices that is entirely right I can
only give you my honest candid view
which is that of all the shadow cabinet
as well that we personally wouldn't go
because of the circumstances that have
led to the World Cup being on the final
thought on David Beckham I mean he was a
superstar he wasn't when um he got sent
off
um I think was 96 I can't remember now
um and then and then he was again and
now he's being absolutely pillared in
the papers this morning what's your
thought a bit later than 96 I think I
think probably France 98 but anyway
we're talking about previous World Cups
look again all VIPs sporting icons
who've chosen to do this will make their
own decisions but I I think some people
are going to suffer an adverse set of
consequences for their own reputations
because these are serious issues that
we're talking about here like you say
this has been a matter of life and death
for many people in relation to you know
the construction of those World Cup
stadiums and I and I don't think we can
get past that fact